>>> RIGHT.
YES.
RIGHT.
I SHOULDN'T HAVE TO KEEP TELLING
I THIS.
OKAY.
DON'T CALL ME WITH EXCUSES.
JUST CALL ME TO TELL ME THAT YOU
FIXED IT.
I'M NOT YELLING AT IT.
I JUST EXPECT MY ASSISTANT TO
WORK AS HARD AS I DO.
WHAT?
YEAH.
MERRY CHRISTMAS TO YOU, TOO.
OKAY.
♪♪♪
CAN I HAVE A COFFEE TO GO?
OH, AND ONE OF THESE DANISHES,
PLEASE.
♪♪♪
>> HEY!
DO YOU WANT TO KEEP GOING?
♪♪♪
>> NO, SERIOUSLY, I CAN'T SHAVE.
IT'S FOR A PART.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN A PART?
WHAT'S THAT?
>> A ROLE IN A MOVIE.
>> WHAT?
>> YEAH I'M JAMES FRANKO.
>> YOU'RE JAMES FRANCO.
>> YEAH.
>> OH, MY GOD.
NO.
I SPENT OVER $1500 ON YOU TODAY.
WHY DIDN'T YOU SAY SOMETHING?
>> I MEAN PEOPLE GIVE ME FREE
THINGS ALL THE TIME.
I'M A FAMOUS PERSON.
>> GET OUT OF MY APARTMENT,
JAMES FRANCO.
>> DO YOU WANT AN AUTOGRAPH OR A
SELFIE?
>> OH, MY GOD.
THAT REMINDS ME, I THREW MY
PHONE OUT.
>> YEAH.
I FEEL REALLY BAD.
>> GET OUT.
>> OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
SHOULD I LEAVE THESE BAGS?
TAKE THEM?
>> GET OUT JAMES FRANCO.
OH, MY GOD, I CIRCLED JOBS FOR
YOU IN THE PAPER.
>> WHAT KIND OF JOBS?
I DO A LOT OF JOBS.
>> OH, NO, DON'T DO THAT,
JAMES FRANCO.
NOT HERE.
>> YOU HAVE A BIG HEART.
I HOPE YOU KNOW THAT.
>> OH, THANK YOU.
>> "DISASTER ARTIST.
>> WHAT?
>> THE "DISASTER ARTIST.
IT'S IN THEATERS NOW.
>> ARE YOU STILL HERE?
GO HOME.
GO TO SET.
>> I HEARD THE PHRASE "OSCAR
WORTHY" A COUPLE OF TIMES.
>> MERRY CHRISTMAS,
JAMES FRANCO.
♪♪♪